hey everyone is fares register nurse RN
calm and in this video I want to be
going over our weekly in clicks practice
question and don't forget to check out
the other questions in this series so
let's take a look at our questions the
physician orders 10 units of human arm
and 12 units of human in subcutaneously
before breakfast daily you are required
to mix these two medications in one
syringe for administration correctly put
in order the steps for how you will
perform this procedure withdrawal 10
units of human arm clean off each vial
top with alcohol prep dawn glove inject
10 units of air into the vial of human
our withdrawal 12 units of human in two
equal a total of 22 units in the syringe
roll the vial of human in in between the
palms of the hand inject 12 units of air
into the vial of human in and wash hands
so this particular question is one of
those drag-and-drop type and click style
questions that you may encounter and
what we need to do is we need to take
these steps right here and put them in
the correct order for how we will mix
insulin and while you're doing that you
want to be thinking of some things to
make sure you do this right okay first
thing what do you think he is what kind
of influence am i mixing together
okay the physician has ordered human are
specifically ten units and human are is
a regular insulin and it is short acting
so any in for name like goblin or human
are those are your regular insulin and
when you look at the insulin in the vial
it will be clear like this the other
type of insulin you're going to give is
humulin in and you're specifically going
to be giving 12 units so the total
amount that you will have in your
syringe will be 22 units of insulin 10
of human are and 12 accumulate into
equal total dose of 22
Kunis now if you millennion is
intermediate and when you look at the
solution of your intermediate action
influence they will look quality like
this next thing you want to be asking
yourself in how do I mix this but first
what is the whole reason why we would
mix insulin in one syringe well patients
who receive influence are diabetics
they're constantly getting injections
and checking their blood sugar so if we
can save them just one less injection
that would be great so really that's why
we like to mix them in a syringe so the
patient can just get one injection
instead of two separate one now when you
mix insulin this is the really big thing
you want to grasp in your mind if
there's a certain way of how you draw it
up and you will be drawing up from clear
to cloudy so you're going to go for the
clear solution first which are which is
your human are your short-acting then
you're going to go to be going to your
cloudy which is your intermediate your
human in so clear the cloudy another
popular way that you'd like to remember
it which i think is really easy is our
in register nurse you're going to go
from the regular draw that up first to
the mph and intermediate now why don't
we draw up from clear to cloudy what is
the purpose of doing it this way well
the reason is because we don't want to
introduce cloudy insulin which is your
NPA into our clear insulin vial now
remember whenever you're using these
vials these are multi dose vials meaning
you and other nurses who are going to
have this patient are going to be
constantly using these vials back and
forth and we want to make sure everyone
follows the same steps they withdraw
from the clear first and then go to the
cloudy because it's these if too much
quality gets into the clear it can
change the action of how the insulins
work well you may be asking yourself
well enough syringe you're going to be
mixing clear and cloudy and cloudy and
clear they're going to be together
what is that going
affect the action well after you put
these in the fringe when they're
together you have 5 to 10 minutes to
give this dose before that action starts
happening now with the multi-dose vials
these we use them up for several weeks
and they will be setting together
they'll be there longer than five to ten
minutes and so that action can happen
over time if more keeps getting added to
this vial over time we can cause that
action to happen now let's set our
options in order okay what is the first
thing you do before you perform a
procedure you're going to wash your
hands then after that you're going to
dawn gloves you're going to put those on
that steps - okay that was the easy part
now we're getting to the part that's
going to make us think okay before we
actually withdraw the solution from
clears equality we've got to do several
things as prep works so the first thing
what we want to do is we want to mix our
vial of cumin in our intermediate
actions insulin remember it's cloudy
because those are those file sets there
for a while that contents will go to the
bottom so how we want to do that is we
want to take the vial and we want to
gently roll it in between the palms of
our hands some mixes you never want to
take and just shake it up and down
because that makes air bubbles so we
will do that that will be step three
after that we need to clean off the tops
of these vials with alcohol prep because
if we inject our needle through those
vials halts and hasn't been cleaned
we're going to introduce the bacteria
that's on top of those tops inside of
the vial which will contaminate it so
that will be our next step
step four okay last part of the prep
work we need to pressurize our vials so
how are we going to do that in order to
pressurize the vial you are going to
inject the male absolution that you're
going to actually withdrawal from the
vial so for instance what we're going to
do is we're going to prep the cloudy
vial first because we want to withdraw
from the clear
so first we're going to prep the quality
so we're going to inject 12 units of air
into the human in the cloudy vial so
that will be our next step now we're
ready to move to the clear because we're
almost there where we can withdraw our
solution but we need to prep that vial
so we are going to inject 10 units of
air into the clear insulin the humulin
are so that is our sixth step now we are
ready to withdrawal the clear insulin
then we go clear to cloudy clear first
so we're just going to keep the needle
in that vial after we've injected that
pin unit of air we're going to invert
the vial and we're going to withdrawal
our ten units of humulin our so that is
the seventh step now we will withdrawal
our needle and we're going to go to the
cloudy solution and we are going to
withdrawal twelve units of the cumin in
and on the syringe you will see the
plunger it will go all the way to 22
units because that is our total dose so
now let's recap so the first thing what
we're going to do is we're going to wash
our hands and put on gloves then we're
going to roll the vial of the human in
which is the clouding influent in
between the palms of our hands then
we're going to clean off each vial top
with alcohol crap then we're going to
inject 12 units of air into the vial of
human in which is the quality then we're
going to inject 10 units of air into the
vial of the human are which is the clear
then we will withdrawal 10 units of
human are which is the clear and then
we're going to withdrawal 12 units of
human in two equal a total dose of 22
units in the syringe okay so that wraps
up this video on how to answer this
inquest question be sure to check out
our other questions our quizzes and our
in flex four new lectures